what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and Marvel fans have been extremely
happy recently a lot of info is coming
out about Deadpool 3 one of the most
anticipated Marvel films in a really
long time and well really just ever
since the Inception of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe we knew that the
X-Men could not be a part of the MCU and
when the X-Men films began back in 2000
we know that characters like Iron Man
and the Hulk could not show up in these
movies and at the time no one expected
that because a Cinematic Universe had
not been developed the Spider-Man movies
were going on at the same time and there
was no crossover between Tobey Maguire
Spider-Man and Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
now we've heard that this might be
happening in Avengers Secret Wars and
we'll continue to keep our fingers
crossed for that and hope and dream
about it each day but in the meantime we
finally have Wolverine in the MCU in his
classic yellow comic suit this has been
a treat for fan fans but we have some
more news that if true might really
excite some fans but also might get on
some fans's nerves as it looks like the
Scarlet Witch could be the main villain
if not one of the villains of Deadpool
3. now I say this could irritate some
fans because some fans are kind of tired
of seeing Wanda as the villain they're
kind of over the villain Arc and want
her to be a hero again well she goes
through a lot in the comics and she
isn't always the best hero in the comics
so we're not too far off here especially
if you consider the events of House of M
which appear to be playing a little bit
of a role at least in Deadpool 3. one of
the things that we've heard the most
about Deadpool 3 is that Deadpool and
Wolverine are going to visit a universe
in which the X-Men rule over that
Universe with Magneto being in charge
well if this rumor going around is true
then it's going to be insane what we see
because it could be that Wanda from the
8-3 eight Universe could have possibly
created a House of M situation in her
respected Universe now the a38 universe
is the universe that the Illuminati was
in and Doctor Strange and the Multiverse
of Madness and in that Universe the
Scarlet Witch took over that universe's
838s Wanda's body so the Wanda that
killed the Illuminati was the Wanda from
the a38 universe but was being
controlled by the Scarlet Witch from our
main Universe earth 616. now we have had
reports from some very reliable insiders
that Wanda from the 838 universe is
going to appear in Deadpool 3. that part
isn't the crazy rumor Alex P from the
cosmic circus in a response to a tweet
about when we will see Wanda next
responded this way there's a lot of ways
to answer this because it depends on the
Wanda if you're referring to Wanda 616
from our main MCU timeline she'll be
teased in Agatha coven of chaos if
you're referring to Wanda 838 then
she'll have an appearance in Deadpool
and Wolverine mothers home now mother's
home is not the title of Deadpool 3.
that's just a fun pun on Wanda so we
have a report that 838 Wanda will be in
Deadpool 3. in the latest rumor coming
from the Twitter account at coven of
chaos states that the main plot of
Deadpool 3 is House of M with Wanda
having turned Earth 838 into a new
version of the hex after the events of
Multiverse of Madness doubling down on
her villain Arc with Magneto being her
adopted father in the new reality
Deadpool being assigned by the TVA agent
Paradox to investigate Loki style Logan
kidnaps Deadpool and takes his temp pad
now on top of the rumor the account also
theorizes that what if 838 Wanda
actually does this to fix the incident
that happened to her during Multiverse
of Madness and this could very well be
the case because this is kind of what
happens in House of M Wanda goes through
many different trials and a lot of
Devastation in the Marvel Comics and in
the House of M storyline Professor X
reveals to Magneto that he is no no
longer going to be able to hold back and
control Wanda's reality warping power so
he goes to the X-Men and he goes to the
Avengers to talk about what to do with
Wanda and which they decide the best
option is to kill her well her brother
Quicksilver overhears this and quickly
returns to Magneto and his sister Wanda
Wanda is sleeping but he tells Magneto
everything that he heard the X-Men and
the Avengers arrive and just as they
arrive they all start to disappear they
find themselves in a new reality with no
recollection of anything that happened
before except for Wolverine but in this
universe Magneto rules over basically
the entire universe he does rule over
all of the mutants and the mutants or
homo Superior rule over the humans or
the homo sapiens Magneto rules with his
children Quicksilver and the Scarlet
Witch by his side and what's interesting
about this is that some of the
characters who were dead like Hawkeye
find themselves alive in this universe
but again no recollection of what
happened before and this could be
somewhat of the story that plays into
Deadpool 3 and why Wanda could have
created this new House of M type of
universe we know that the Illuminati
died in Multiverse Madness and although
it wasn't really one to herself she
could blame herself for some of the
events that had happened and we know
that although it was not included in the
movie Magneto in this universe was
supposed to be Wanda's father this was
revealed way after the fact when the
movie came out so what if Wanda does the
same thing in this universe that she
does in the comics in the comics they
eventually find out what had happened it
was actually quicksilver's fault
Quicksilver convinced Wanda to create a
different Universe where everyone's
wishes came true Wanda had a family
Magneto was the ruler over the humans
and the X-men Spider-Man was married to
Gwen Stacy and had a kid Carol Danvers
was Captain Marvel and was the most
beloved superhero Captain America was
retired and so on and so forth everybody
essentially got what they wanted so
after dealing with so much chaos and
destruction and Trauma that took place
in the a38 universe due to the sky the
witch dreamwalking perhaps the Wanda
from the 838 Universe tried to fix
everything that had happened because she
felt like it was somewhat her fault and
created a new universe one where Magneto
rules and she's at the side of her
father and if you are not aware for some
point in time in the comics Magneto was
revealed to be the father of Wanda and
Quicksilver however that was retcon to
not actually be the case eventually down
the line but for this story in the MCU
that very well could be the case in an
alternate universe Magneto could be the
father of Wanda and Pedro and this would
explain how Deadpool and Wolverine could
come across this universe where Wanda
could actually be the villain because
she is the one that created it and
therefore is the one who put Magneto in
this power and this could mean that she
could revive Patrick Stewart's Professor
Xavier Black Bolt Captain Carter John
krasinski's Mr Fantastic so there is a
possibility that we could see him again
and the other Heroes that have fallen
and the most interesting part about this
is when Wanda created the House of M
Universe in the comics Hawkeye was
revived in the new universe but finally
when it inverted back to the old
Universe they found out that Hawkeye was
actually alive in the real universe and
Doctor Strange explained that the events
that took place in that Universe really
did actually happen so Wanda or the
Scarlet Witch resurrected Hawkeye so
Wanda or the Scarlet Witch could bring
back the heroes that died in Multiverse
of Madness in her actual Universe not
just in a different alternate reality
created by her however we do know that
the TVA is going to sort of hire
Deadpool just like they did Loki in Loki
season 1 and perhaps it's Deadpool and
Wolverine's job to essentially take out
this universe and prune it now what's
really interesting about the set photos
that have been released for Deadpool 3
is that it looks like Deadpool and
Wolverine could actually be at the void
and here's where my Theory comes in I do
believe that they are at the void we see
a 20th Century Fox logo in the
background in some other photos we can
see a ship that is there as well and it
essentially does look like what we saw
in Loki season 1 the void my theory is
that perhaps Deadpool and maybe
Wolverine got sent to this universe to
try and prune it but they themselves
ended up getting pruned therefore they
both got sent to the void if the TVA is
having a problem themselves pruning this
universe then Deadpool probably won't
get it right the first time and if
Magneto was in charge and the Red Guard
is working for Magneto which the Red
Guard in the comics is actually Shield
but just mutants one of the members
includes Tony Stark well I imagine that
Deadpool and Wolverine will probably not
beat them at first so they could get
pruned and find themselves in the void
and this is where the conflict between
Deadpool and Wolverine could happen it's
clear that Deadpool at some point in
time seeks the help of Wolverine stating
that the job would probably be easy but
after losing to the X-Men in this other
Universe Wolverine might get kind of
pissed off and say that he's done this
could also be why he takes Deadpool's
tint pad stating probably that he's
gonna go back to his own universe and
telling Deadpool leave him alone and
this is where the fight could come in
Deadpool wants his temp at back so he
tries to take it and here's where we get
our fight now of course ultimately I
think after the fight they're going to
come down and try to do it again and
probably are successful maybe pruning
this timeline now it doesn't mean the
a38 universe won't exist but a branch
from that universe will probably be
pruned but this could be how Wanda could
in a way be a villain of Deadpool 3.
perhaps not the main villain because I'm
sure there's going to be more to
Deadpool 3 than just this exact
storyline but it looks like she's
certainly going to be somewhat of a
villain in Deadpool 3. if this rumor
ends up being correct we've already
heard from an Insider that she is indeed
going to be in Deadpool 3 and I
personally would love to see her create
an alternate reality House of M style
but let us know your thoughts about this
in the comments down below would you
like this or would you not like it let
us know everything in the comments
please don't forget to like the video
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items as well we pick one
winner at the end of each month and the
winner gets to pick one item you can
also follow us on Instagram and Twitter
you can support us on our patreon
account our website or join our Discord
server as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching wolf wolf
baby